hey guys this is desta founders day care
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the hunger games
catching fire which is the second in the
movie franchise based on the popular
book series right so like the you know
the first movie I liked it but I
definitely like the first half of it
more than the second half and in this
movie I think all of it was done pretty
well I mean there were some things I
didn't like about it but overall I
thought it was much better done yeah I
mean it looked better the special
effects put more money into it I've
always appreciated about this series
even no matter how big the scope is it
still kind of has a smaller film feel to
it you know doesn't feel too grandiose
even with all the special effects but
this is definitely much more time and
effort put into this bigger production
value they look great yeah yeah so
before we go on we're we're gonna talk
about spoilers and this thing we I think
would figure that most people are gonna
go see it there knows you seen this
weekend delivery man no they're gonna go
they're gonna see it because you know if
you like the first one you're probably
gonna see the sec one if you didn't like
the first one you're probably not gonna
watch by this one because it's it's kind
of more the same but better in my yeah
right I agree so let's start off on what
were your positive stuff that you like
positives uh first off I like the way
they handled kind of going towards the
end of it like why they handled the
Hunger Games competition and the season
it was much shorter one because we spent
so much time you know last with the last
film within the you know in the arena
and if I know it's basically the whole a
big chunk of the movie this one was a
chunk of the was much shorter kind of
got right to the point another thing I
liked about it you know you're not talk
about was casting and did it even a
better job with cash and of course Woody
Harrelson is always good Jennifer
Lawrence continues to be a good actress
but a lot of new actors I enjoy too yeah
I thought one of the main improvements
for me was that the games itself was a
lot better yeah in the first movie I
like the first half build up to them
going into the games and I think the
first mate the five minutes when they
first go up to the games I thought was
pretty cool yeah but then it kind of
started to lose me as it went on and on
and right you know the virtual dogs and
all that money we care for it where this
one felt more like okay
they're in the games these are the
dangers and you know even stuff like the
fog I was like oh man don't get caught
by the fog right yeah boys this fog I
mean there's some good scenes I mean of
course when what mags the character of
the older woman I loved it felt kind
like a Luke Skywalker Yoda thing with a
guy you know having run her back home in
inglewood yeeah for the gif a lot like
hey I like you finna character he's
actually one of my favorite guys I
thought I thought he's gonna be annoying
cuz he's gonna be like too cocky yeah
boy right he was cocky but I mean he had
good qualities yeah really cared about
magazines oh yeah he was carrying mags
on his back and I come on that you gotta
give him props for that he really
genuinely cared about her right in the
context of the movie and and you know he
he had a love interest back at home
again and so he kind of was an honorable
person despite his you know cocky nature
and I like the way they created him I
mean it's very subtle cuz it mentioned
like how he's good under water and
what's one of his weaknesses like well
his strengths are he's been underwater
he almost had a Triton like tried in
like they like the the staff you know
they like King Triton would have or
something like that so it was cool like
i like the little touches uh I think
that's thing I like the cast of
characters I like the I guess we called
villains I mean they're not really a
villains with the kids that are the bad
kids about killing people to grow with
the fangs and of course i love that we
got some older people like with Jeffrey
Jeffrey right yeah Jeffers every right
being it with how he's smart he's in the
science to it amanda plummer made of
Lemuria yeah yeah definitely the cast is
better in their older too yeah it's
another thing because the the last one
was like all just kids right there's all
kids but because these are all the old
victim all the old Victor's coming back
you're seeing more experienced people
with different type of skill sets where
before it was just a bunch of ya young
kids like going at it you know so just
didn't seem I don't know it wasn't
didn't seem as dangerous right you know
I remember there was like like a be seen
or something to her salon yeah that
seemed a lot deadlier like they were out
to get people and kill people quick this
time no more hiding the woods for days
on end so no I mean they got to the
point quicker the beginning part was
good for me I think I like the second
half of the movie better but the
beginning part was good got a little bit
more Liam Hemsworth in this one you know
because i needed to i feel bad for me
kind of pops up on the screen and he's
gone
you know I mean just because you know
he's away from capital you know the city
so well speaking Liam Hemsworth in the
the character of Gail I just don't find
that in that relationship very
interesting no heavy they given us
enough to not only that I just I don't
know I guess the chemistry between
Jennifer Lawrence and he has what I just
I don't know maybe I just don't buy
right now it just doesn't do it for me I
I think like with PETA in the last movie
was kind of a worse you know yeah well
he's a liability he's always get hurt
he's was the most hurt all the time but
in this one I felt like he he stood up
to be even though you could tell he's
you know still in love with Jennifer
Lawrence's character uh you know Katniss
Katniss um he was more of a man in this
one yeah and so I liked his character
more and i also like their relationship
more that was a one of the kind of
negative things about the movie but i
understand why they did it which was
there was a lot of exposition especially
the beginning in libya I did because
they needed to explain a bunch of stuff
the good of the world not only build the
world but they had to explain some stuff
that wasn't explained very well in the
first move all right for example in the
first movie you don't know that with
Katniss and Peeta like the kiss in their
relationship is is something she's doing
for the the TV audience you know but
they explained in this one right in some
expedition they're like oh you have to
do this bubble balls and then explain
everything and then you okay that's why
that happened but I did feel like Peeta
and Katniss his relationship was better
in this one because then you got to see
like even though she you know she
actually never really said she was in
love with you know yeah she cared about
Gail they're dating or whatever but how
her relationship with PETA grew because
remember PETA is the only other person
you know that that she's like with that
knows what she's going through yeah I'm
usually what I mean Helms Rose character
does get it doesn't really know as much
as he's he's working the mines whatever
he's doing he's not he's not in it on
the ground with her and
in the games never been through the game
no doesn't know it's like to like have
to kill like other people really no
reason only PETA on a relationship level
then hey mitch is almost like a mentor
yeah and that's you know again what
heroes is the man you he's just doing a
great job via playing Hamish but uh it's
good yeah I mean it was good as a lot
more developed on more story going into
it it's not too many weaknesses III love
philip seymour hoffman as i can do the
new games master i like that i think
he's a great casting choice you kind of
always knew something was i were the
first ones i really know was gonna
happen to somebody like you always kind
of knew something was happening because
like the people were like remember who
you're fighting for like all this stuff
like wait did she sacrifice herself in
the middle of competition and you knew
like I felt like you know closing
happens probably a good guy because i
wouldnt have that dance in the beginning
any other service bad it's just some
mysterious writings you're so you can
again so you felt like there's something
else going on behind his character and
of course at the end it's revealed that
he's part of this conspiracy of
revolution with with Katniss as like
almost like she's the figurehead and
less of like actually moving the pieces
cuz he's the one who didn't know what
was actually going on which is
interesting and I'm curious to see what
its gonna be look at the next one
because it's almost like yeah she's
being used as a pawn yeah maybe it's a
pawn for a good reason it probably
should be a revolution but at the same
time she's still being used like she
doesn't really she's not driving this
thing forward so I don't know mission to
see what happens yeah yeah and uh what
do you think about where the the movie
ended I mean it was it was sudden yeah
but being that we know the series that
they're trying to they're going to milk
this franchise like Harry Potter you
know going to split the last do like
Twilight they're going to milk this
franchise so it you know I had some
forewarning going into it so I kind of
expected it but the same time it didn't
bother me that was a good point later I
heard I heard the book ends at that same
rightly so I don't think it's your the
audience were like who yeah people who
in rid of books right we're like Oh what
happened right where's the rest of it
right it's like it's coming over the
next you know gonna keep keep going come
on boobs laughs and then what do you
think of what's his name Senna's death
Larry Oh sonica
is it Seneca god the former games master
no no no uh lair lenny Kravitz's
character oh yeah oh he's beat up who
know if he's dead though I raised them I
heard we liver the book so we don't know
yeah the books I've heard he was dead
but I mean oh no okay honey uses beat up
you possibly could be alive right you
never know that was sad if he's okay I
guess I don't really feel much for girls
like oh maybe they'll come rescue him
but if he's here that's sad i like let
it Kravitz yeah I like this character
he's he's not playing who you think he
would be you know and with the whole
fashion designer saying kind of
flamboyant I mean he's he's great i mean
thats sad if he's dead well he's using
his his the fashion is like a state a
political writing yeah well Mockingjay a
win everything and yeah I would suck if
he's dead another thing I liked about
this movie is like it definitely had a
bigger scope the games did it felt like
a bigger area with a lot more going on
the capital was a lot felt a lot bigger
yeah and also they were traveling from
in the tour they're traveling from duty
to district which we didn't really we
saw flashes of other districts in my
first one but nothing this one felt more
like okay we're actually get to see more
of even where Katniss lives right plus
like the other districts we felt like ok
these are the places that are hurting
yeah I got to see more of the revolution
why people feel the way they do and
because they were like just reading that
the speech you know and just saying all
these words that were fake and we were
like we want to hear the truth want to
hear what you think so I mean yeah
it'sit's interesting Donald Sutherland's
character as the the president you know
just trying to quell this this this
rebellion here's oh yeah because you
have it it's basically Katniss versus
the presents no rights it's like this
battle but they're not physically
battling it's all like political
maneuvering through right kind of
through television and the audience
they're like they're battling through on
that one Stanley Tucci's character yeah
he's grazers these rocks oh yeah the
girl on fire that's that stuff like and
he's trying he's maneuvering by like
making the hunger games like this and
trying to make her in a poor life I mean
it even went so far as to affect his
granddaughter's school I mean with her
hairstyle yeah he's like all
all the girl everybody's when the hair
start like this now I mean it's it's all
and she's like oh I wish I could love
someone as much as that right yeah and
you know inside he's like demon this
girl affected my granddaughter now yeah
alright so what are your overall
thoughts and grade for for catching fire
those grits thought I'd give it a go to
be plus i think the series still has
room to improve but i want to go too far
giving a minus or negs think it could
still get better but it's definitely an
improvement over the first one just look
better visually and just production wise
i definitely give it a B+ definitely
recommend to go check it out okay i'm
gonna give it a B+ / a minor yeah I
think maybe cuz you know I it was to me
even though I like the first one I
thought it was a vast improvement and I
think those improvements really like
made me feel better cuz you know cuz the
the production of this movie was pretty
a quick turnaround I was kind of worried
with a different director and I was like
oh man this might end up being a mess
right but it didn't it seem like they
they kind of had everything in line yeah
we're going and did everything so i
definitely recommend especially if you
like the first one yeah i go see it for
so yeah so you can post your comments
below on the website thank hero calm and
on our youtube channel thinking or pro
make sure you subscribe to that you can
also check us out on twitter flip to
Dennis or myself about anything we're at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we have
some a facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans and make sure you
like that page and you can share and
tweet or videos that really helped us
out thanks
you